[музыка]
по экспедиции все равны ни у кого нету
вы не количество денег и статуса не
должны ничего нет они возраста тоже все
равны все равны все
почему потому что смотреть я заметил
такую вещь когда больше всего ну может
быть но и сравнение очень хорошие
больные люди не любят когда от него
просто как бальник багаж алматы активный
социальный проект для особенность том
что он делать социальные проекты и
делает жилье для малоимущих которые не
дарит а он дает на до тех пор пока этот
человек не выправит самое положение
связывать ильяс я тотчас сам отель
разные есть направление бизнес
ресторанный бизнес энергетики который
temirlan
строительство занимаемся даже
земли потом а рыночная есть и
недвижимость в аренду для mizar доска
здесь гордо трал
они несколько направлений без сейчас
остановим приставать
магазин меня зовут cornelia родом из
молдавии сегодня я живу бухаресте наш
бизнес и в молдове и румынии то есть
модели мы производим мебель продаем его
надо ли ее
гармонизация мы снится
но у меня был бизнес
аренда недвижимости коммерческого сейчас
старается всего этой цели как бы
переосмысление сейчас новые остановка и
какие-то этапы но
посмотрим же zafar город алмата станок
сфера деятельности строительство
еще есть производство биггза сама ты
пересек
иначе может быть снимать я для уликс
алматы ты заговоришь финансовыми
инвестируем анабель
вы супруг до 8 лет
меня знали то ли я с украины с киева у
меня ведь я компания производит контент
на таких платформах и праздник у нас там
аудитория больше 100
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
поехали выжмет кто первым ультим я буду
мне баги 5-ти водитель один
погибло нет нет баги четыре монеты 2
после обеда magician баги 7 водитель два
после обеда roly poly 6 водитель баги
шеи базе один водитель 2-х баги баги
3-го деле 20 до обеда багирова баги 2
вот я на позиции support'a
одели вот это застегнули вот это раз
если ветер вы можете вот так если совсем
вот так из липы или или чет играет 350
генерации так ребята дадут этот
подшлемники по шлемник и еще комфортнее
это у нас все и для симок после этого у
вас отбираем полностью симки
съемки телефоны кто как хочет кто-то
можно телефона кто-то симки отбираю
почему потому что первая цель для
успешного проведения обучения это
детоксикация цифровая детоксикация
потому что когда телефон вот так лежит в
городе вы выключили уведомление на самом
деле вы выключили только звук
процесс аватара да какой аватар кто
первый подходит бы до завтра должны
придумать себе аватар а и мы говорим
аватар отнесите соответственно потому
что это достаточно придирчива
процесс инициации игру кто от имени
богдана приехал экспедицию когда-то
процесс инициации сюда подойдите так от
имени богдана к нам присоединился к
родам
с этого момента на всю экспедицию ты не
багаж когда шастал со мной модель этот
человек который приехал от имени бардаш
с ума от ими во логика нам в экспедицию
в воде отправил абрама момент оно все
есть перед экспедиции ты
слишком много размышляя подумал что
классно будет если это будет кайф просто
никуда от имени виталия к нам
присоединился к и
зовите его край ровный край
если я вам понадоблюсь зависит
от имени назад к нам присоединилась и
мамкин
от имени биоса к нам экспедицию
присоединяется жен барс
или тамерлан окна присоединяется магас а
ты мне камелия к написанию сара и
меня скота к нам сатрап приехал чаки
имени коннор как нам присоединился ещё
я силу присоединилась томирис
имени
даулета к нам прибыл идрис шах
от имени запара с нами зов а
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
федина
роду
[музыка]
но можно
но
[музыка]
друзья близко к обрыву не подходе
придавлю пойдёт вода виды рыб
[музыка]
я приехал в эту экспедицию моя цель
прежде всего переосмыслить свою жизнь
свои цели еще главная составляющая
внутренняя то есть даже само название их
вниз и переосмысления высота что ее
внутреннее содержание и даже как она
спланировано то есть распорядок это мне
тоже очень сильно за те совала вспомнить
что нужную ценности что главное что
второстепенное
выключить телефон и оказаться где-то в
другом месте абсолютно другой обстановке
чтобы
подумайте обо всем
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
поспать не знаю что будет дальше .
страшно высыпал пары часов послал просто
жесть
с непривычки
[музыка]
[смех]
примерно
а
[музыка]
последнее время вот начинают путешествие
воды хорошее подспорье вот другая среда
это не как норма путешествие которые
придут и дубай турция какая другая
реальность так сказать
короче вот это вот это все вместе я стал
практически стала магистром попер вообще
я хотела сюда приехать мангистауская
область
в актау во-первых потому что здесь очень
много святых мест и но никогда не ездила
почти не идет казахстан и хотелось
понять вот все-таки это моя родина
[музыка]
это первая экспедиция вот я собирался в
в прошлом месяце лететь в дубай но я
узнал об этой капельницы и я подумал
почему бы не поменять дубае на вот эту
экспедицию где будут скорее всего очень
классное окружении глину ценности здесь
я понимаю что получу больше чем просто
пойти в дубае поэтому просто за меня для
меня большим открытием было к за что я
люблю пространство в целом да на это
спасаться от яда при весьма из как бы на
одном уровне а вот раз мне получил свою
увидите пространство то есть с высоты
птичьего полета если что то неописуемо
жало
вот туле атомная бомба упала и тогда
когда в песочнице играешь раз как тот
кто то надавил такое ощущение что здесь
такой кто-то большой так надавил что она
так именно именно эта часть так красный
села сейчас у меня прям память о стоит
знаете
утро давите я в одном бани вместе 8 5
приехали там ощущение от этого стада
управлению мне сама по себе чувство
нравится ну давай твоя недолго и звонок
пробу ну а каца долги есть и два чипа
другом допустим дубае ты там папа баку
апа есть поездки очень так и не уйти не
успевать прочувствовать машину а здесь
нет а какое продолжение ну да вот jus он
это все все прям сидение мощные это
стандарт оказывать нам правду на типов
мигают
даче обвинить кого-то с собой домашний
комплект из в нем видишь
настоящая жизнь за окном она баги ты
едешь внутри этой жизни и потому что
меня дети не на впечатляет что я люблю
когда нет у горизонта из крайне
может таки мелкий слабый да и так это
могущество природы где силой вы может и
вот
смотреть жигалова потом долина конечно
ушами почти
да да да по долине и потому что там тоже
есть пространству и тут есть тип за 1
оперения летят так и здесь люди примерно
на 1 еду
но как эмоции почему-то вот на фоне этих
локации меня зацепила природа это
сегодняшний закат все-таки когда мы сюда
заезжали и это было вот и вода и горы и
это но я думаю что это один из самых
крутых
закатов ну а конечно локации все по себе
они
крутые там
пошли и вообще немерено . не только три
там да это четко понимать что красота в
глазах смотрящего
[музыка]
вот осадок
by von
детский
вдохе
[музыка]
ты гамбита
пройдите этот
гуляя резкое
escada
на куски по визе
avanti
уединиться
окей smile
детские носки
[музыка]
детского действия толстого едущего
из кельна ст кеды
зив их дом надо
мама
это старые
[музыка]
у меня два хода
подушка эта тема
если честно по казахстану вот так вот
первый раз
путешествия это
очень сильно мне понравилось путешествие
хорошо влияет им она раскрывает человека
но ощущение классное видео всего этого
ты осознаешь насколько прекрасен этот
мир и и увидеть всю эту красоту
красоту вместе с таким коллективом с
такими крутыми ребятами до участники
кстати они прилетели с украины есть
ребята с
молдавии да очень классные ребята очень
открыты и бизнесмены у всех там свои
дела
впечатления если честно очень крутое как
экспедиции там
написано переосмысление да то есть
происходит я думаю переосмысление не это
неизбежно
[музыка]
вот почему я за пять лет
цель экспедиции или загрузку такую
сделать к нам и говорят а
быть
обществе единомышленника пустить все
бизнесмены как
[музыка]
ничего тяжелого как бы весело наоборот
весь его
туризма в казахстане я никогда как бы не
увлекался
интересно просто посмотрите какие места
у нас в стране есть
и честно удивлен потому что даже не
предполагал что здесь как бы такие есть
реально эксклюзивные места даже в мире
которые каждый нет суп и жаркое шас еще
чуть-чуть сервиса прикольно это моя
можно похудеть пару килограмм
постесняется я поймал
бриз
у нас 4444
я все он может выбежать зависимости от
настроек
[музыка]
наша и наношу и по пустыне не очень мало
будет локаций поэтому завтра думаем о
проблема как раз хорошее время во первых
завтра будет будет казаться что те люди
которые вас отправили сюда они живут
где-то далеко
ну методом новый у них от них уехали
город уже чувствуете как город уходит
[музыка]
подготовка экспедиции у меня не так
много времени заняло так как я здесь в
экспедиции для меня было сделано
исключение я
попросила добавить меня в экспедицию
именно по моему костромской области
к сожалению сегодня покидаю группу
в основной группе желаю счастливого пути
доехать до моря до арала и ждём хороших
новостей
[музыка]
а
из птиц а именно вот такая она первое
вообще в моей жизни именно
то что ночевать палатках тому подобное
решил себя проверить это новое для меня
ощущения но вы ведь ищу тебя проверить
вот в пыли вон в грязи пожить и мне это
тоже определенный как своих квесты и что
тоже интересный документ и
без телефона самое главное что
[музыка]
понятно чек зажегся перешли в аварийный
режим работы
все чем дома и я парень
помашем теперь это 1 и
стежок проворного .
айда
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
except the brands are certain брандау
сказок хазарами сразу сказать ломбарды
за национализм дом брамс он там нас ssd
нафармить тендер клитор порно перед walk
alone знак
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
ну зачем я приехал то я и получил и
получаем здесь очень важный момент на то
что данном случае мне важнее именно
внутреннее содержание
[музыка]
сегодня пошел какой-то тектонический
сдвиг
потому что мы не искали приемы мы не
искали какие-то действия прямые которые
приведут к эффективность в нашей жизни
мы сегодня работали над сменой
именно нашего аппарата мышления то есть
как мыслить по-другому как мыслит на
другом уровнем другой стандарт и сейчас
голове так и прыжка обвал такой же как
мы видели в первый день новая что это
благодаря юрте она имеет вот такое как
купол где вот мысли генерируется но в
правильную сторону я рад что экспедиция
продолжится и каждый день приносит нам
новые открытия себе и погружение
[музыка]
а
бренности бытия надо жить здесь и сейчас
мы переживаем
идет
ручка
путин сколько бензина сеанса вы короче
смотри вы же по грейдеру приехали
правильная вдоль nexia газопровода назад
сюда возвращайся я нахожу 70 километров
по грейдеру холод базу и у нас
заканчивается бензин утопив босой пока
прям щас таких базы давай
[музыка]
заправили бахе
[смех]
последних вы кого-то даже не вытащить
[музыка]
какие галка
pink
не помогали
запах уже дом очень вкусного что это
кто-то из наших советов
приехать сюда строго либо
[музыка]
уже получаем какую-то информацию
допустим с утра течение дня едешь
youtube через себя пропускаешь и многие
вещи которые у нас корпуса моей жизни да
и вот
со поставляешь по своим действиям по
другому уже смотреть на многие вещи под
рукой призмой другим углом
количество и качество информации
плавит мозг ходим с такими бутылочками
остуживаем постоянно чтобы чуть-чуть
хоть как-то он приходил себя жара в
пустыне просто кажется прохладой по
сравнению с тем качеством и количеством
информации которое попадают наши мозги
невероятно
[музыка]
иное состояние
как ни странно пустыня 50 градусов жары
и холодная вода это просто нереально
круто она заряжает
санта не надо
этим животным
итог энергии на спасибо за такую прыть
адскую спит и сыном от explorer
он колечек
[музыка]
[смех]
у
мы
всегда всегда думал я всегда ноль думал
вообще в целом дома почему так что
могу просто у нас потом вау лет нет
такого как городские когда охранники на
откровенно там савик это отдельного
часа тут просто время такого когда
родители уже как друзья подруги идей в
наш крем родители того так гильза
оберегая войне я паника
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
прошло 7 дней мы ездили на баги мы
видели невероятные красоты объект или
полторы тысячи километров а вот но все
же больше всего конечно понравились наше
общение наставление маргулана и я точно
себя славился дня на мысли что я уже
другой человек и действительно
перезагрузка и переосмысления но
произошло что получилось за 7 дней
получилось увидеть себя по-другому
увидите мир по-другому и самое ценное
наверно что я взял для себя с этой
поездки это
ощущение понимания
мысли разбегаются просторы ты понимаешь
ближе безграничен я могу все если захочу
там а так и здесь смотрите когда вы
несете же на баги баги олицетворяет
жизнь дух
неуправляемую жизнь вы несетесь iru
дорога
непредсказуемое но она у
этот багги под названием жизнь гдеж ты
вообще дорога и баги это
кончи
территорий от жизни дискомфортно 2 чел
раньше но ты
у себя там что вам будто
давай теперь
там учился
чего стоят что ты так
нет ни скольку в
без безопасности .
ос любой
случится для настроением пайол всех
сразу ниже плюс
дискомфортных ощущений
безопасность прежде всего приоритета
а есть какие-то такие несущественно вещи
не
хочешь сломался мода
баллоны проткнул эффектом колесо улетела
яркое впечатление с ними-то что
первоначальная мы окунулись в отзывов в
пыль я всегда ассоциация пустыне то что
такое жара там какая красота может быть
в ней на и я сам псалма тренды
в моем представлении что красивее гор
могут быть только горы в этот раз я уже
увидел тоже пустыню с другой стороны
тоже по-своему очень красиво яркая
основана помогу стал ездили вот это
bajirao как мы на нее поднимались и сама
на баги
яркое впечатление это ночные ночью
возвращались это что-то такая дикая
гонка
ночью степи ты ничего не видишь акта
было раз два раза таких деталях даже
больше моментов когда
приостанавливались
пыль оседала и все никого нет тишина не
света фар не видно
[музыка]
какой такой
такое впечатление
дизайн это такие эмоции в ночная ночная
гонка это для меня это сильно ночная
гонка на багета для меня тоже очень
сильно впечатлил сейчас представлю уже
что сейчас буду включать телефон есть
что там меня ждет и уже это уже такой
такой
привет стрессовые состояния уже
начинаешь входить также команда так
темно
вещи тоже
отработали на все 100 поэтому
мое впечатление
просто большая благодарность большой
респект всем
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]